the Red Corner standing at 6-2 199
pounds
going against in the blue Corner
standing at 6-2
187 pounds Nick Davis moving touching
gloves touching gloves oh oh low light
tap oh oh face shot
all right
foreign
the original five crew we're here again
nothing's changed this week actually
we've got our guest uh comedian uh shoe
plugs
uh host of podcasts
doing everything I can to stay out of uh
out of Uncle Sam's way hell yeah for
sure just another uncut yeah is that is
that that's your stage name well not
just Justin Elliott Justin Elliot for
sure
the only the only reason I put the uncut
is kind of like just like unleash got
you you feel me like uncensored Oh I
thought it was uncircumcised that's what
a lot of a lot of women
a lot of women come to me and tell me
that why you thinking that I don't know
why Christian we didn't know we need to
monitor that but uh yeah I do the uncut
just because Justin Elliott was taken by
a dude with a hundred followers and uh
I'm still trying to bribe him to get my
name does he ever reply hell no man I'm
trying to get him blocked just like
trying to get them banned like say he
was like doing some type of freaky [ __ ]
online but report him yeah everyone
that's listening to this episode just go
to Justin Elliott on Instagram not
Justin uncut go to Justin Elliott and
report it so Justin can get I love the
idea I don't want to get uh the thick
boy YouTube channel in trouble for
berating so don't do that
yeah yeah but that's not a bad idea yeah
no but uh honestly if you actually
search Justin Elliot I'll probably be
the first person to pop up anyway so
don't go to yeah don't listen to
Christian advice and then go to my my
name and start reporting me because you
know people don't know yeah I don't see
why that guy just wouldn't respond to
you maybe you might throw him up bro oh
I don't I don't want to give a number
out but you might you might pay the man
so I had one of my uh my fake accounts
follow them and uh he hasn't posted
since like 2008. been real quick not
seen anything then that's what I'm
saying that sucks I got low browse um I
bought it from a girl for 50 bucks it
was a cat's Instagram like a kitten that
had like huge like black eyebrows no and
it was little brows I was like I need
that and she just changed it to little
browse one and here we are fifty dollars
fifty dollars later that's what I'm
talking about yeah I was worried that uh
my another podcast network account got
hacked because like I couldn't get in
yesterday and then it was saying like oh
uh confirmation email sent to and it
gives the first letter and the last
letter of the email it says gmail.com
yeah and I was like [ __ ] I don't
recognize that at all so I'm trying to
DM the account be like hey please give
it back but it's one of the guys I
co-host with and you didn't even like
know he had that email we just used it
because we needed it so crisis averted
and horrible story
[Laughter]
you know I think our names I mean
because of the business that we in is
very important of how we Market
ourselves right I got freaking hacked
the other day not too long ago it was
like a good like four months ago five
months ago had my whole Instagram name
changed and it was crazy man I was so
hurt it's like it was like career
suicide when you get your name Checker
you know people they looking at you and
you posting still and they looking at
you know booty looking 17 at the top of
y'all
they'd be like what the [ __ ] is going on
for real so it's like man
you know Instagram we put a lot into it
but rightfully so you gotta have that
that good name yeah it's like a it's
like your personal scoreboard that's
your kid's wife you're like what have I
done in my career like like you said for
this industry it's it's a little bit
much though how much we I don't know
from the numbers
it's your brand like Justin said it's
your brand it's your whole like online
Persona like you can't you like if you
don't have that then people are gonna be
like who the hell are you yeah uh I
should also I didn't say the name the
think before you speak podcast yeah it's
Justin's podcast everybody seriously
stop go subscribe now let them go
subscribe I need to I need to get it
back going man I haven't man listen I
haven't done an episode in a minute
because you know like listen y'all are
blessed to be in the studio and doing
the pot it take a lot to to keep a pod
rolling you know I did one unpaid for
six years so yeah I feel you I feel
everybody so it's definitely it's
definitely a Hustle but definitely check
it out because we definitely gonna keep
it back going what's been up with y'all
man I haven't seen y'all in Forever I
know right two weeks right
I haven't seen y'all yeah it was like
what was that San Diego yeah yeah we
were talking off camera that it felt
like so long but then they're like wait
it's only been what two weeks a week and
a half week and a half it was all in the
green room just chilling uh having a
good time we went to Philly had some
real good steaks that we need to start
you know we just started taking some
some guys trips you know you don't take
no guys trips like outside of work on me
you know yeah oh without the same house
you mean or what are you talking about
Mommy no no no no like no shows no shows
no I mean it doesn't matter who who
comes but just just the fellas just
hanging out because you know if you
think about it when we go out we doing
work yeah you know what I mean like we
actually
trying to make a name or build that
brand but we don't really I mean yeah we
have fun during the day we have a lot of
fun yeah we do a lot of sightseeing and
stuff we got rained out yep yeah I love
the idea though more boys trips like I
do with like my friends for back home
but like the people in La it's always
like work related but even I can't turn
it off you're like oh let's do a boys
trip I'm like let's let's film it yeah
right right right right that's true
that's true it's content baby but I mean
at the same time it's like how often do
you go
on a trip and you just sit down and you
just relax you just in the water
chilling in the sand put the phone away
no well I don't know but you know what I
mean it's like
just we don't have to work every day
sometimes I feel like when I do so much
so much content or just so much work I
feel like man I'm about to blow a gasket
so it's like [ __ ] if I just take a few
weekends off
go out of town hit a beach maybe a
little honey dipper too you know what I
mean yeah I know yeah stop recharge your
batteries you seem like you're on grind
24 7. are you feeling any burnout or
yeah I take little Retreats like uh I'm
trying a lot lately this guy yeah
recently I'm in Grind Mode but I go like
I was camping for a while by myself
camping I was camping I took a little
tent went to uh what's the place I told
you I went I forgot what it's called I
forgot Sequoia I want to hear more about
this because like I romanticize the
thought of like going on a camping trip
by myself I'm like I don't even know
where the [ __ ] to start like where would
I drive like you did you talk to someone
I'm gonna be honest here's what happened
I went up to Sequoia
he didn't even make it I already
no that that really is what happened I
went up there I did I thought you had to
like I didn't know you had to reserve
all this stuff I thought I could just
post up with a tent wait you can't it's
not that easy
into the town I got a motel room the
lady was like I'm glad you didn't post
up out there it's like bear season right
now you're completely unprepared
um you're gonna end up like [ __ ]
Christopher McCandless at the end of the
wild for real eat some berries and die
next to a van yeah
School Bus yeah great movie
um wait so you you you can't just go in
the woods and just post up like you have
to actually why it depends on the land
so if it's like the national flowers
yeah I totally I didn't know it was a
whole thing yeah I need reservations and
all that is there like a Hostess like at
the beginning of the woods like oh yeah
sometimes there sometimes there's like a
front like little you know brick and
mortar small little tiny office and
they'll check you in sometimes it's that
or they just they do the honor thing
system yeah so as long as you paid for
it your site's there it's reserved but
some of these campsites you have to I
mean campsites get books so fast I had
to look into like four or five months
yeah just just families and just friends
wanted to go out into the you know
quote-unquote Wilderness but that's
always so everybody in here has been
camping I mean I never had to pay for
growing up I literally would just go
into the woods with a like a sleeping
bag and stuff and like find like a rocky
yeah like
okay
I probably can't more than anyone here
yeah it's like every weekend yeah I try
to go as much as possible I've never
been camping shocker but I mean like
dude you would be so boys trip let's go
camping no I'm down
look I feel like we go to DC you feel me
we do something like that uh a lot of
times though Justin you know yeah
I love Thailand I would love to go get
on there that's a little tough it's a
little tough for us go to UK something
like that I don't want to go camping
okay where are you from again I'm from
Miami that makes sense to why you've
never been camping then I feel like well
I mean yeah because we don't really well
I mean they got woods but you know we we
got First 48 out there so it's like
that's where most of the woods come in
handy where a murder is happening so uh
yeah we don't get camping like it wasn't
even until I moved to LA
I even knew about hiking
right hiking was a new phenomenon to me
I walked there
then they got several Hills that people
tried not just one it's just like where
they got running people want to go uh
they got this other one in Porter Ranch
that I I went to and I was like this is
there's one of them the only hiker he
knew is that guy on Price is Right uh
who went up the hill all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
the mountain climber game Price is Right
no sound please that yes damn y'all
quick that was good oh yeah
I've never you've never watched prices
right now I have but I don't remember
this part they had to guess the price
and then it yeah for every dollar is for
Real oh okay I remember this
but I didn't put that in oh let's talk
about that little cardboard guy not a
person he's got a there was a hiker that
died who was on Price is Right I think
oh I did two for a second I was like
wait what are you talking about no let's
talk about that okay everybody has a
different idea of camping though because
when I I went as a kid we'd go with like
our cousins and our grandma would bring
us and we had my great grandpa's camper
and we pull up to like a slot it was
called Beaver Creek State Park in
Caledonia Minnesota with the glasses and
the shirt right now it's really painting
the picture
this is the first time I've ever had
glasses on in a minute I'm out of
contacts but uh we'd pull up to these
these campsites there's like a dirt
driveway and like a little fire pit and
then 30 30 feet there's there's some
Hedges and another campsite and it was
just like this is camping yeah they did
have Trails or whatever and we'd walk in
the creek and we'd catch lightning bugs
and [ __ ] you said then we'd go into the
camper that electricity and uh watch
Aaron Brockovich
[Laughter]
it's very specific
I mean
I think going out and camping is you
know it's just the outside elements that
I'm worried about
um like uh would you what do you mean
like uh mosquitoes
I'm 100 with you on that that's the
smallest type of I mean we could I just
watched a video not a video but it was a
story I saw of a lady who got mauled by
a bear while she was camping
you heard about this story pull it up
Christian
right yeah she initially fought the bear
away
the bear shoot away came back and ate in
asleep
first of all lady if you shoot the bear
away the first time what make you think
go home that's what I'm saying let me
you got you got bears in the area but if
you go camping you should bring a like
especially a Kefir in an area with bears
and [ __ ] you know what you're getting
into I think you should bring a gun well
if you're allowed to or bear spray you
can carry or so bear spray 100 but if
you carry a gun
laws too like you can if you're in a
tent it's not like an actual Outdoors
you're in your home it's like a dwelling
or something I don't know that sounds
right yeah I heard something like that
but I don't know for a fact so I
wouldn't listen I would not suggest
people hacking I don't I don't think I
don't think the police are going to be
coming by and checking your tents and
like I've never been checked so yeah so
yeah so if you can get away with
bringing it then bring it hey it's
either you get the bear or the bear gets
you yeah that's basically how it is
space Raptor get clapped did you hear
Sandy from Grease died I did yeah
135 pounds oh yeah uh Contender future
champion in my book coming zooming in uh
he's the man he does an awesome story
which like I probably won't actually ask
him about maybe we'll talk about him
later just because it's like it's hard
for him it's like me bringing up the
Olivia Newton-John thing for no reason I
just brought everything gravity down we
reflected I was trying to segue and do
new topics should we play the video or
no uh which one the one that you sent
about Adrian and that's so good minutes
so probably I was gonna say like maybe
like a couple of clubs yeah uh what is
she playing huh UFC UFC easy guy oh no
I'm talking about Olivia Newton John
what is she playing yeah what is she
playing you know Greece
yeah yeah
so you didn't hear that no no no no no I
I knew that she died because but you
didn't know which person I didn't know
yeah yeah the uh [ __ ] good girl the
bad girl
um
you know she was a singer too
you not know that you don't get that
money
she ain't getting anything anymore hey
Christian I'm pretty sure her estate
still gets get something yeah
yeah the states do
next week uh we're gonna start that cats
after dark trivia contest we have the
contestants set the first round is going
to be playing for the final eight I'm
still writing the questions and it's
just I'm taking too much time with it
but it's hard to find good questions
because I'm like that's too hard that's
too easy Justin we're gonna do a thing
because we're supposed to be an after
show of King of the sting okay we barely
talk about it y'all do your own thing
yeah yeah but to do it more we are going
to do a ultimate King in the sting fan
trivia contest and we have 12 people
zooming in we're gonna see who knows the
most about the show oh dope but there's
a lot of [ __ ] legwork involved I'm
working on it but it's gonna be a good
time I understand that definitely yeah
what else are you up to Justin you
traveling at all just traveling doing
shows getting drugged that's pretty much
how oh yes you did mention that uh
earlier uh it's not I didn't get drugged
is uh so you didn't go camping you
didn't go drunk did anybody do it
no I I was basically in a situation
right you know how many people in this
room a day
or oh like have a girlfriend or just
read it out that's right
we go on dates yeah yeah that's good you
should go on date no no no no no no
you're not dating right now no get out
there he's single ladies get him up not
right now six five two lady
that's about three inches a little too
much the hell out of me what's up you
surprised the hell out of me your height
when I first saw you everyone says that
too when they meet me they're like I
thought you're gonna be a lot shorter
right yeah I guess I look like a short
guy I was an OG listener so I knew you
were
I was also surprised by his age honestly
I thought he was a lot younger bro dude
he just said him hey how dare you Justin
hey just like hey Justin's like I didn't
know you were 50 I'm like come on come
on turn it around two years old don't
know the real number though because I've
heard I've heard them joke so many times
yeah lots of times it's Chin's 50. yeah
you're 38 45. it's Joe Biden here's what
I'll say
I'm closer to 40 than 50. I'll say that
much so 43. he's the most he's closer to
50. are you getting older every day
44. yeah
we could think he's 41. no actually
and not that that matters some of you
are right something's wrong it don't
matter what is that old until the
regrets take the place of Dreams
is this is that a stoicism or uh no it's
a it's a quarter here oh okay it's an
original quote from Nick Davis can you
imagine dude that's poetic y'all over
here drinking all these nice drinks you
watching you got to drink you got uh
everyone's responsive I'm over here got
this uh McDonald's cup that I had to
bring in myself
this is a coach at the moment this is a
coachable moment
Christian is
believe it or not the producer of this
[ __ ] all right
so Christian your job when we have a
guest come in
get this man refreshed I thought he was
refreshed he came prepared I thought I
didn't know we need him we have rock
star whiskey or something like we're
kind of I mean not from what I watch
online right you know you guys have the
nice setup and everything everybody's
having a great time I thought I'm coming
in getting a red carpet treatment y'all
treat me like I'm some type of stepchild
a huge part of the business model is
smoke and mirrors
way too far back are you sure I'm just
talking to you all right
yeah I mean after whiskey or beer or
Rockstar or I'm not drinking right more
like I said oh no I ended up uh so
again back to the who's dating right
you're going out on dates
sometimes when you out
you know you might have a little drink
or two right and I don't know about
y'all y'all tolerance I mean Nick you
seem like alcoholic but I mean
I'm a blackout drunk oh so you black out
yeah I'm not like I'm uh I like to
delineate I'm not an alcoholic like I
don't wake up have to have the bottle
next to me I don't drink every day I
drink maybe two three days a day
three days worth you're on a roll two
three days a week two is honestly really
accurate but I'm a problem drinker so
when you drink so on those two days you
go hard Smash and yeah and in like Hawks
man I always go in like oh because it's
usually Tuesday Thursdays I'll record
when another podcast Network everybody
check it out learn that movie check it
out check it out yeah yeah another
podcast show we'll record three hours
I'm like I'm just gonna have one white
claw every show we do we do three shows
a night gotcha no I'll end up uh at the
bar and then I'm like partying for no
reason and like this isn't what I I
meant to do and then also blackout and I
never think I was drugged I'm an extreme
ownership in that respect I was like I
did that to myself time traveled do you
get hungover pretty bad or no I feel
like on occasion right now I would
because I've been eating so like good
yeah and little so like I have nothing
dare you bro huh is that how dare you
yeah we're doing a weight loss
competition he's gonna lose 600 to me
for no like I don't know why you did why
are you doing it wait wait why what is
this discipline bets
numbies numbies but you're trying to get
trying to get more fit physically fit no
I am Christian
if I can do it
and he's already way big he's way ahead
of me I'm skinny as [ __ ] I know but then
I'm gonna bulk up then I'm gonna try to
rope someone in at the end of it to get
into a weight game have you ever okay
that's my plan so then I'll do another
month and win another six hey at least
you got at least you got a plan at least
yeah at least you got to track because I
don't think that Christian Bell should
go work out but it might be a situation
what's going on guys we're just gonna
take a quick break to talk about cats
after dark's newest sponsor manscaped
you know later in this episode I'm gonna
be boxing chin for one minute and before
this boxing match I needed a little
confidence boost and I don't know about
you but one thing it gives me a ton of
confidence is shaving my nuts so that's
exactly what I did and I did it with uh
manscapes performance package 4.0 inside
the package is the lawnmower 4.0 this
electric trimmer really was my Excalibur
to get the job done shave my nuts so I
could have confidence to then box Shin
later in this episode stay tuned to find
out who wins and honestly they this
trigger is designed to reduce grooming
accidents and shave hair on loose skin
thanks to a ceramic blade and the
Advanced Skin safe trademarked
technology this stuff's incredible I've
got the cleanest nuts in the game
whether or not I win or lose to Chin uh
later in this episode you'll see you'll
see what happens get manscaped use promo
code cats ad for 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com that's catsad
for 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com shave your nuts and fight
chin this episode is also brought to you
by Magic mind that's right magic mind
it's the once daily shot the magical
Elixir to help you do more and stress
less start knocking stuff off your to-do
list rather than seeing it grow uh I
know I procrastinate a lot but I I have
a lot less since I started taking magic
mine daily and quite frankly I'm
addicted to it it's it's simply 30 grams
of caffeine in a matcha based uh couple
ounce shot but that 30 ounce
that 30 milligrams of caffeine is
combined with an Alchemy of uh 12
natural ingredients that's going to give
you a nice focused Zen hump throughout
the day do more stress less go to
magicmine.com dark use promo code dark
for 20 off that's magicmine.com dark
promo code dark for 20 off now uh let's
get back to the show how much do you
think I weigh
looking at you
I say or any other I was just indicators
I would say like
170. yeah see I was 199 when we waited
10 days ago I'm not 187. okay which is
freaking insane
yeah and probably 185 because I weighed
in today with clothes on I'm trying to
get down to 155 is the goal I wouldn't
wait 198 yeah Nick that is insane but
why 155 why 155. ultimately because I
think it's funny if we're gonna be
completed and he's serious about saying
this is gonna be funny I'm gonna start
thinking like they could like yo what is
wrong with Nick yeah but that's gonna be
fat and six weeks later so then they'll
be like what's wrong
real Nick in and we're gonna happen to
put an IV in them just to keep him awake
I weigh 155. you believe it I've had uh
I've actually been eating like pretty
big meals but it's it's a like this is
what I've had yesterday I went to Spitz
this is place in Los Feliz and I got
this giant lamb salad double protein but
that's all I ate all day and the day
before that went to the habit I got a
giant Cobb salad which has avocado and
eggs and I put double protein but that's
all I had all day damn and I feel pretty
[ __ ] fresh that's a burger place
oh yeah any exercise or no just uh yeah
yeah I actually you go to gold you said
you went to goals I went to Gold's
Glendale yesterday oh did you but uh
yeah I've been I walked to go get this
food and how tall are you six two
Nick you can't go down to 155 yes bro I
bet I can't I'm five five and I'm 155
pounds of water weight
um
it's really good I thought you was five
feet no don't ever disrespect me like
that again Christian don't cut you're at
least five feet so you're taller than
five feet you
I am five five
do you want so bad we gotta classify
listen I am five five I can't believe
I'm arguing about that damn usually I
tell people I'm five six five seven but
now I have to argue that I'm actually
five five like my real height man God
damn that's [ __ ] up uh you got a
second grossberg coming yeah it's coming
what's weird is you can't be six two and
five one fifty five no well we'll ask
we're gonna have you want to get him on
the horn Adrian Nunez we're I'm gonna
ask him about the weight cup process uh
because I I think I'll be down to 170 by
the time speak of it it's like three
days before and then I'm gonna do the
weight cut which would be like 15 pounds
of water weight are you fighting anybody
yeah can you hear us didn't you guys
spin last week yeah oh oh yeah I'm
fighting some of the day
how do I make it so he doesn't just see
me
uh switcher oh the uh black magic atem
oh that's funny he was just one-on-one
with Christian yeah I was like why is it
like so close up to me
it's the one that says uh 810 mini it's
got a green uh egg on the end the white
cord
yeah
okay no Refreshments for Christian or
for Justin no cords plugged in we're
working on it man give Christian a break
man he's doing he's doing everything he
can
doing a great job but we can uh talk
while he's trying to figure this out
Adrian you know you can't see us uh just
picture uh a white guy and an Asian guy
at a desk
we're both six two it's a black desk
that's pretty we both have glasses on we
do Adrian you know me what's up it's
chin yo what's up good to see you again
that's the worst Ouija board experience
ever
but uh and then on the video part part
on Zoom I'm sorry for the technical
difficulties we're having on our end
yeah on the bottom of the video drop-up
can you go to Blackmagic where if it's
not showing up
all right just turn your uh camera or
computer around
can you see us yeah
you could probably get all four of us
now
like if you angle the
thing right
yeah there it is that works yo
all right someone's getting blocked by a
stand but I'm okay with this the brother
man what's going on Adrian uh I'm stoked
to have you been uh found you since your
Contender series fight uh and we heard
you're a fan of kicking this thing I
know you've already been on the shop
show so thank you for doing that Adrian
that was awesome and not man thank y'all
for having me on man like it's been cool
man I've been listening to like all the
uh all the podcasts like you know the
slew a podcast like for years already so
it's like it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool to be on here yeah the tumultuous
six months in the podcast world huh
progress
[Laughter]
uh nice oh you have your screen recorder
going through the whole time nice uh
cool and you're obviously beefing up
your setup you got the mic you got the
headphones are you gaming are you doing
podcasts yeah uh more more along the
lines of gaming and then also too uh I
got I got hooked up with Jen's Pulver
and we start doing like commentary every
once in a while like uh we do the
contender series every Tuesday every
Tuesday we'll we'll uh pretty much
commentate over the fights uh on Twitch
so it's another little Avenue too and
then also every once in a while I'll do
a pay-per-view with them every once in a
while so we'll do watch alongs and all
that stuff but I do like the game and I
do like to talk about fights anytime I
game too so like yeah perfect dope I'll
check that out for sure are you doing it
tonight uh yeah I'll be doing that
tonight with James pull over on the UFC
channel so that's oh it's gonna be fun
oh so yeah yeah bottle nickels on
tonight and you know I'm actually pretty
excited about that one yeah I know you
think it's gonna go
and uh man he has uh he has he's when
you have wrestling that good like the
guy that you're the the guy that he's
fighting is gonna have to be worried
about to take down the whole entire time
so it's just gonna be like he he won't
care about the guy other guy taking a
shot Bo's just gonna be I feel like he's
gonna be able to be at free range to do
whatever he wants but you know it's it's
gonna be a fun one the guy that he's
fighting is Pretty Tough he also kind of
did take a short note so uh I see just
bow nickel just like running away with
this even though like uh the other guy
comes from a promotion uh that's based
out of Texas uh and I'm all about Texas
guys but you know just Bo Nick was just
gonna run run away with this I feel like
hell yeah and I mean the odds think he's
like minus one thousand or something
he's minus three now mine is three
thousand yep good oh God yeah first
fight minus three thousand that that's
what that's wild
um
so not all our listeners are necessarily
MMA fans kind of a general show so uh
we've got a guest in Studio Justin
Elliott comic uh I don't think he's an
MMA fan can you explain to him short
version elevator pitch why Bo nickel is
a big deal I don't know what's going on
oh yeah no so this is uh he he does
commentary on Contender series which is
kind of like a they do four fights and
if you do a really good performance on
this Contender series uh then you can
get signed to the UFC oh dope and this
guy Bo nickel is fighting tonight and
he's got a lot of hyper on him dope yeah
no this this guy at Bow nickel man he's
a phenomenal wrestler he's just an
absolute Beast like a lot of people man
he's a
this guy uh he's he was brought into uh
uh Jorge Mazda's camp like just to help
him out with the the wrestling for Kobe
and Usman and all that stuff so this guy
is like his wrestling pedigree and
taking people down and like just being
able to take him down stay on top uh is
super super high like it is so so high
uh and you know that kind of opens up
his hands uh for him to throw like I
think in his first uh in his damage in
his professional debut he didn't even
take the guy down he just like knocked
the guy out because the guy was so
scared about being taken down just kind
of left out everything open but yeah the
contender series man it's super dope
because it's almost like uh I don't know
uh uh it's almost like being it's like
pretty much you're going in for an
audition type of deal and that's that's
the weird part that's the weird part
because even if you are
even if you like are like you do win
and like a lot of these guys can look at
you like wow we didn't like your style
there's been plenty of Fighters where
they've been super dominant but they
just didn't like them they're like all
right cool next that type of deal so
that's that's the weird part so it's
it's a weird audition so that's that's
also the cool X Factor with the
contender series you said they got four
fights that you have to do in order to
get no there's there's basically uh four
to five matchups so there's gonna be
five different fights between two people
but just because you win in that fight
doesn't mean you make the UFC you have
to have like a really impressive
performance yeah which doesn't always
just mean Knockouts I can't remember the
guy's name but he's got long hair and
he's fought in LFA recently since but he
had a wheel kick knockout [ __ ]
highlight knock someone out cold but he
didn't get signed because the the three
three rounds prior to that were like he
just would not engaged he was just
waiting for the moment and that's not
what Dana White wants to see there's
actually a video if you can find it uh
actually don't okay yeah yeah but Dana
Dana White after the first so it goes in
Seasons they'll maybe have like six
episodes of it at a time uh every year
and each week or one episode a week and
and on the first one it just came back
last or two weeks ago and Dana White was
pissed because all the fights were kind
of like there was some laying prey there
were some people who wouldn't gauge and
he came out and he's like he signed one
guy who won who had a really impressive
performance and he was [ __ ] pissed I
don't care what you did in your career
the last five years what are you gonna
do tonight
so next week when you roll in here the
next crew on Tuesday
show me who you are Tuesday night that's
the only thing I'm concerned with and
it's should be noted Adrian uh he came
onto the scene on this Contender series
with a knockout in 30 seconds oh no no
yeah yeah that that was that was a life
changer for me man that after that fight
everything else kind of just skyrocketed
and it was it was pretty cool man but
also it was like that weird feeling that
everybody like
like at least right now they have uh
they have a little bit of fans in the in
the stands like me whenever I I was on
there this was right when covet had shut
everything down so I could literally
hear a pin drop like it was that quiet
and just looking around I I could hear
people answering their phones and [ __ ]
and that was that was the weirdest part
about it I was like whoa like who the
[ __ ] is in the back is talking to their
mom right now what the [ __ ] it reminds
me of Johnny when Johnny Drama went in
for uh uh audition in entourage and he
just flipped out so because some guy was
uh texting on his phone he's like what
the [ __ ] and it's probably instead of
auditioning he's fighting fighting it so
what is like I mean so when you are in
the moment about to fight right what is
your mentality is it like I gotta rip
this guy's head apart or you trying to
like stay on the technique stay to the
game plan
do that man honestly it really depends
on what fight it is uh the contender
series one where I was doing like pretty
much the audition for like for me
getting into the UC like that one I
zoned in it was almost like uh like
every once I stepped into the cage
everything kind of just tunneled tunnel
vision in and like I because I knew at
that moment that I needed to focus and
if I had to let one thing slit my mind I
was gonna be on the other end where I
was on where I wouldn't get the contract
so I got super zoned in uh my debut was
a little bit different uh short notice
opponent I had a full Camp uh that that
one I was just like I'm just gonna have
fun like I'm I'm here I'm gonna enjoy
the moment uh so whenever I was in there
like I just looking and seeing Bruce
Buffer call my name I was like oh [ __ ]
this is actually pretty cool uh was that
Brady Wang
yeah Brady Brady Wang in the uh uh in
the contenders then Victor Rodriguez
from our uh profession for my UC debut
uh the one where I had to keep it all
together was this last one uh Tony Kelly
yeah Tony Kelly that one uh just because
like
that was my first time fighting in front
of fans and fought in front of like
Austin Texas in a sold out crowd uh
hearing the Roars and then all of a
sudden like uh
right before we were walking out I see
him like in front of the curtains right
before he walked out and I could see him
behind the curtains uh with a little bit
of light he's flicking everybody off and
like walking out flicking everybody else
off and he comes out like I remember the
song vividly and he was talking about
hate it was the song it was about haters
it had Wiz Khalifa on it and like I'd
never heard the song before uh and I
just remember just being in that moment
you know like man [ __ ] this guy for
somebody just like [ __ ] a good [ __ ]
like this guy walking out that was my
heart was like I thought my heart was
gonna be beating out my chest but I was
like it felt comfortable uh but the part
where like my mind kind of just was like
almost went into the oh [ __ ] mode was
whenever I was inside the cage and they
started announcing my name and like the
crowd Roar Just Like because everybody
there hated hated Tony because he's
flicking everybody else out there just
and he's like flicking off the fans he's
saying [ __ ] you grabbing his balls doing
all that [ __ ] and me I'm the baby face
I'm the baby face and that and that uh
that situation and I'm looking up I'm
trying not to let the moment get to me
but I see like my name in the in the in
the headlights and the lights and [ __ ]
and I'm just like oh [ __ ] this is for
real like and I had to pull myself right
out that moment because I was like I
gotta get focused because if I don't
man this this this this guy is about to
look yeah he's about to look like a
villain and he just took out the good
guy and [ __ ] so I was like yeah I
couldn't let that happen but I it was a
weird that one was weird because I had
to snap myself back into it and when I
did I was like it was on an incredible
ending and I mean you say baby face but
this is like Stone Cold baby face he
knocks out Tony Kelly and then he gives
him the double birds
and like a lot of people didn't think
Adrian had like that mean Street you
know they knew he's a killer but people
think Adrian's a nice guy baby face
assassin
no man it was it was crazy because you
uh the UFC staff just didn't like the UC
staff have has never came up to me and
been like thank you good job or like man
that was so [ __ ] awesome that you did
to that guy uh because I've only fought
like nothing but super nice guys like
Randy Costa a super nice guy like
everybody loves him like I have not
heard one bad thing about Randy same
thing with David Grant like everybody
loves them I remember telling them was
like who are you fighting I'm finding
Randy oh that guy is super sweet like
okay
and then I was like who are you fighting
I'm like baby Grant oh that that he's
such a sweet guy and I'm just like yeah
all right cool and then I then after
this guy who you fighting Tony Kelly oh
that guy's a piece of [ __ ]
that's what I was gonna ask you like do
you take anything like personal
sometimes
because I I watch even though I'm not a
UFC buff like you guys I watch it on
Facebook watch a lot it comes up like
those little matches that come up UFC
kills I watch a lot of old fights on
Facebook watch like it comes up on my
Facebook watch right so
when I watched the little weigh-ins
sometime or the little showdowns like
people be having these like crazy faces
like towards their opponent like they
about to knock them out and then like
they end up being the ones getting
knocked out in their in in the video so
it's like do you ever take anything
personal when you what happened well you
say you had all nice opponents but yeah
no uh this guy I ever nothing was really
personal until he was making it personal
uh that like he like because everything
like because I don't know if you know
the backstory behind that was that he
kind of uh he was cornering his
girlfriend and uh in one of the UFC
fights and he pretty much uh called like
the girl but but he didn't call the girl
necessarily A cheater but he was like
that she's a dirty Brazilian uh that's
what they do they cheat and pretty much
everybody took that and ran with it it
was like this guy's this guy's a racist
which he does have show a track record
of kind of saying some pretty uh [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah can I say can I say Adrian
I feel like that you can find an
argument uh where like that's defensible
and like oh he's just like I don't know
like because that's kind of a thing like
yeah within mixed martial arts like oh
there's like dirty resilience who like
do sneaky taps or whatever but there's a
myriad other evidence that this guy is a
piece of I don't know I have evidence I
didn't know I only know beautiful I'll
say I'll say I'll be honest there's the
point there's like uh there's some
comments I was remember looking through
Instagram and like because I like at the
point in time after the fight he was
talking [ __ ] and he was still continuing
to talk [ __ ] and then even in the
comments somebody said something
somebody says something like man the
Latino beat your ass or something some
some things along those lines and he
said something about like Latin he
started like he talked [ __ ] about uh
Latin people like eating dirt and [ __ ]
and I'm like oh oh now you're like now I
know you're wrong
and on top of that like his uh like I
don't want to speak on his girl but like
this is just kind of facts like she was
dating she got guy who had like uh like
his a guy that had like a a swastika or
yeah
they're like the SS tatted off yeah can
I tell you like a weird coincidental
story is she bad I I uh Justin she's not
bad
this is Andrea KGB Lee who's also a UFC
fighter by the way KGB uh that's her
nickname yeah
um so I work for a mixed martial arts
equipment company yeah yeah yeah she's
pretty badass
um I was working for a mixed martial
arts equipment company in like 2013 and
I went to a Muay Thai tournament in Des
Moines and she had left she was at the
the tournament and she had left her
sparring gloves at home and her and
Donnie came up to me the swastika dude
seemed just like a nice Southern couple
and she's a sweetheart this guy was
coaching her when she was under 18. and
then married her at 19. this guy's got a
[ __ ] backstory it's it yeah insane
I'm gonna get my [ __ ] ass kicked by
the way uh the way I'm talking about
here but you're just speaking about to
say yeah yeah these These are these are
facts these are yeah
this Donnie guy beat the [ __ ] out of her
one time got arrested they're divorced
now she's dating someone else who's at
the same gym it's really weird but I
gave her sparring gloves I just gave him
to her because she left her spine so
I've been following her through her in
Victor run so that's why I'm so acutely
aware of this story and then I then it
was a huge Adrian fan and he fought Tony
Kelly it's crazy
[Music]
it's great
also a weird story to add I'll add on to
that I had like I had no idea who that
was like who uh Donnie was at all next
thing you know like I get a message on
Facebook like on like tag me tag me in
it and guess who lo and behold guess who
it is it's Donnie saying I'm your
biggest fan you're knocking out that
piece of [ __ ] Tony Kelly and I'm just
like what did I get then the whole story
kind of came like he wrote like a big
ass paragraph like oh man they were
going back and forth that was a whole
[ __ ]
I remember just looking at them be like
nah I'm not touching that at the time
leave it alone dude you don't want to
get caught up in that yeah it sounds
like it's toxic they say like the enemy
of my enemy is is my friend not when you
got a swastika yeah we're not sure it's
a swastika it is definitely a Neo-Nazi
or Nazi symbol that he didn't want to
remove right because he said he said
like it shows part of a history I want
to learn from it but they're like no
dude get up there is a police report
where he was an off duty shot someone
outside his house wait what
should I should we uh maybe I'll cut
that I don't know
do you think American History X is his
favorite movie or what oh absolutely
unless it shows them in a negative light
I actually haven't seen it I know
someone gets curb stopped yeah I saw it
but he changes it's really dark pretty
dark yeah pretty dark man so you
mentioned how your life changed change
change of topic real smooth uh at the
contender series uh you had a full-time
job is this when you were doing the uh
the Water metering yeah yeah man so I
was working I actually I didn't quit my
job until uh
a week before fight week so like right
before I flew up to Vegas no no before
my UC debut oh okay so like I was still
working uh I was still working uh I
knocked I knocked the guy out uh and
pretty much like that kind of changed my
life and sense of like that started the
uh the role of me quitting my job
because I told my boss like hey I want
to end on good terms because I'd never
know where it's gonna where this is
gonna lead me I don't know if like uh if
I'm just if I if I go and bust you know
[ __ ] I just don't know so I was like Hey
I want to leave on good terms
gave them plenty of time to to look for
for new Replacements and all that stuff
but yeah I was doing the water metering
and like pretty much yeah it I love the
job for like
I love the job for the couple days that
I didn't have to turn people's water off
but other than that like it was it was a
great job but those two those couple
days man [ __ ] bro my God damn I hate it
I hated like seeing people be like [ __ ]
any other day any other day is cool but
no you walk up and you like they see you
got that tool to turn the water off
they'd yeah I almost actually I almost
fought this one I almost fought I was
about to say that's right I got your
fighting experience from when you was
out there turning people water off oh no
man I'm telling you like this this this
guy came close to me fighting dirty yeah
I was like I was like man luckily my
co-workers on the other line right now
if not man I'm I would have beat your
ass
during uh the uh your UFC debut I think
it was uh Paul Felder was saying how
much you reminded of um of or it might
have been Victor Rodriguez how much you
remind him of Jorge mazfid all did you
think of that of yourself before uh or
just a coincidence
that part that part kind of came a
coincidence uh you know it was it was
weird actually no no I got I've gotten
that uh resemblance before uh because I
think whenever I fought in my last fight
in LFA uh some like they took a picture
like I remember this very vividly where
like it was me against this other cool
guy named Kyle Estrada you know that
fight if you want to go back and watch
The Banger that was a good fight to
watch uh somebody commented was like Hey
dude I didn't know the [ __ ] College
shot was fighting Jorge Mazda I was like
oh [ __ ] okay yeah I guess I don't think
I live on but you know I'll take it but
after that after Paul Felder said that
it just kind of just became a thing I
was like all right you know I guess mini
street juice I'm cool with that you know
yeah I'm cool with that for right now uh
now I have to pick your bang for uh
brain for some advice
um chin and I have a bat we're doing uh
unnecessary weight cut just so you can
lose more uh weight he was uh I was one
in nine 199 he was 198. when we waited
in the first time he was one in 199 and
I was 198 but also it was on a faulty
scale so we don't know exactly but I
mean I I feel like it's going to have
the same well hopefully yeah yeah
hopeful that it does we have we have to
go buy it okay but uh so I that was 10
days ago it's five weeks total I've lost
12 pounds he's gained four yeah
you know uh I don't think chain cares
much
I know and I'm gonna give you when you
lose with that you give me 600 cash on
this show I'm setting up a whole way
where you can win your money back on the
show all right perfect the guns are part
of it but I may have bought the game
operation
but you're asking Adrian because uh
because so I like I said currently last
I was getting there yeah uh I there's a
plug within a question uh 12 pounds to
what do you think I could realistically
get down to and then I want to ask you
uh specifics on the weight cut three
days before
okay so how much like you said you
weighed 190 199 I have no muscle people
would say people who saw me at 199 be
like your face is kind of fat for what I
see you at I've always been a slender
guy
realistically man uh in five weeks right
you got five weeks still yeah uh okay
except August 30th is way August 30th uh
okay so realistically depending if you
just cut all carbs completely you can
probably lose like 10 pounds naturally
and then three days out you can uh
probably cut like
10 of your weight in water and all that
stuff so that's me at 160 my goal is
155. because if I cut 10 more pounds
that's 177 10 is 17 pounds that's 160.
if you want to push it make it 15 you
can get there you can definitely get to
155 but you're just crazy no you're
you're gonna be looking like a skeleton
walking out you're gonna look like The
Walking Dead I told him he's gonna be
looking terrible we'll see what happens
I have cut out carbs completely in these
10 days to lose this 12 pounds uh wow oh
yeah oh yeah no then also you can do uh
you can do like a little uh a fiber load
before so you'll be waiting a little bit
heavier and then you just start [ __ ]
your brains out and then after after
that you go on to the water the water
loading and then after that once you go
to the water alone you cut all the water
out and you can easily like because I
went from 155 to 135 in a week so that
was 20. so you can you can you can do it
it's definitely doable uh it's just yeah
uh especially you're how tall are you
like six two 60 oh yeah no for sure you
can you can probably wow especially if
you don't got too much if you had more
muscle I'd be definitely yeah yeah
like no you you can make it easier but
if it's more more fat more fluffiness
then no cars for the next couple next
couple weeks to do you good one of my
buddies nicknamed for me in high school
is low toned which is
uh but uh anyway yeah one more question
so Adrian
when you actually finish the fight
everything's good right because you've
been winning like crazy so what's your
go-to meal your cheat meal oh man uh
[ __ ] everything on it yeah like I had I
turned into a legitimate fat ass and I'm
just like whatever's in whatever's in
sight and uh it's usually never the
night of a fight because it's weird
because I I'm not hungry like I think I
would be hungry but I'm not it's usually
the next day where I just start like
eating everything and I my go-to is
pizza of course because I'm a I'm a fat
[ __ ] but also uh
what is it uh now go I go to Wings Pizza
Wings tacos my my aunt makes some great
street tacos and like yeah I'll just get
fat off of that for the whole entire
time and then everything just turns to
me being a glut and I'm like I'm take
I'm gonna eat whatever I can either
Whataburger Jack in the Box all the news
Whataburger shot up like yeah I kind of
want to get a heart attack by that by
the end of the week you know so that's
usually my mindset so so the three
losses in your career uh are all against
one of the guys Levi I don't know but by
his record he seems like he's pretty
good and there's Domingo perlarti who
had a cup of coffee in the UFC but like
also could have not been cut was a split
decision and then miles John currently
in UFC Split Decision I haven't seen
either of those fights they were LFA and
hard to find even though I watched most
LFA do you think you won those split
decisions
no I definitely think I won those split
decisions the the ones that uh uh like
against Moz and Domingo like definitely
uh especially if you're judging off a
damage uh in those fights with uh in
those fights with Domingo and and miles
it was more stalling these kind of
almost like they were sticking to a game
plan like miles couldn't get me down
because uh Domingo was able to get me
down but he was he wasn't able to do
anything with it uh and I had worked on
my wrestling was trying to improve by
the time I got to Miles Johns who is uh
a lot more established in the rest in
wrestling couldn't get me down he only
probably got me down twice and
immediately I popped right back up uh it
was kind of more of him just holding me
against the fence and then when we
separated I landed the shots you know uh
so I thought I would I would have got
the win I rocked him I had hurt him to
the body uh you know I felt like I did a
lot but you know I was in his hometown
as well so it kind of sucked you know uh
but I felt like I won those two fights
the one against Levi I definitely lost
but I'm telling you right now that guy
disappoints me so [ __ ] much it
disappoints me so [ __ ] much because
he he can definitely be in the UFC but
he was just not dedicated to his weight
he'll like he legitimately we're
supposed to rematch uh we're supposed to
rematch later later on in our career
like I was actually two fights before
the contender series uh but we're we're
fighting at 35 but he comes in at like
46. I'm like oh [ __ ] like bro came in
like overweight so that part sucked
uh uh well this is perfect we're running
out of time on a zoom uh so uh I forgot
my one so only one more question
specifically this water oh yeah
top five favorite product podcasts
besides King in the sting you're a
disease fan that would have been
included the top five probably right
yeah yeah definitely yeah definitely top
top five favorite yeah
oh so uh so right now I listen to The
Joe Rogan podcast the Joe Budden podcast
so two Joe's uh and then uh fighter and
the kid uh two bears one cave and of
course I believe it's your mom's house
yeah your mom's house oh wait wait am I
really gonna put that in your mom's
because I do listen to Bad friends as
well too
um oh that's a good one too yeah now
pretty much like the the whole La
podcast thing before they went outside
last question specifically on this water
load what is it so
from my understanding uh so we're gonna
weigh in on a Tuesday
so Sunday I would drink a gallon of
water and then not drink anything after
that oh no so my water loading the way I
do it is a week out so let's just say
you weigh on Tuesday so the Tuesday
before I start drinking a gallon and
then Wednesday I start drinking a gallon
then Thursday I up into two uh Friday up
it's I'm still at two
uh uh Sundays is is two but on that
Monday it's one but the caveat to that
is is like let's just say y'all are
weighing at 12 o'clock your time on
Tuesday Monday I'm feeling finishing
that gallon 12 o'clock at 12 o'clock and
then after that it just all just
dropping weight wow just like sweating
it out and that's miserable yeah I won't
have see I don't have a sauna I'm gonna
uh and I also Uber here but I'm gonna
ask to sit in someone's car we're in
Calabasas it'll it'll suck uh this is my
plan and then uh we're gonna weigh in at
10 30 because we have kicking this thing
that day so uh
so yeah stop try to drink a gallon of
water by 10 am
yeah stop drinking water by 10 a.m on
that Monday uh then that Tuesday 10 30.
yeah just make sure you get some type of
electrolytes in bro because right after
that because bro you
take everything slow get up you're gonna
[ __ ] pass out yeah like I remember uh
I remember one time I just I popped up
after cutting weight and I like
everything just seemed hazy to me and I
felt like I got roofied and I almost
felt fell out like oh [ __ ] so you have
to be very very careful especially if
you're going to be cutting like 20
pounds so yeah yeah awesome too anybody
got any more questions
where can we find you Adrian work where
can uh the viewers find you in like
anything you're promoting like anything
you want to promote or anything
uh as of right now Instagram Adrian is
93 Twitter Yanez MMA Facebook I have too
many friends that don't add me uh also
uh I had I partnered up with
millions.com with Bruce Buffer and I so
we do all my merch through there you can
do AMA so you ask me anything on there
uh but yeah no everything everything
else yeah uh
twitch ninja Yanez that's you know add
me on there too follow me on there too
so I'm not really professional with this
stuff but you know hey it is what it is
yeah you're killing it you got a fight
schedule
uh no I we're we're in talks right now I
am hoping to get the name that they that
they've been you know they've been at
like every single call I get off with
them it's the same name but there's no
confirmation on that person's side
because I'm yelling yes
I would have said O'Malley had he not
been booked with Jan uh but could could
you give us a hint or no oh he's top 50
he's top 15 for sure there you go top 15
uh and yeah he's yeah you know I'll give
you even uh better uh nice a better hint
he's top ten okay damn yeah [ __ ] yeah
well I'll figure that out when we let
you go uh but um thank you so much man
uh it's super dope to hear you listen to
this [ __ ] yeah because we're a huge fan
thank y'all so much appreciate you on
and uh future champ thanks for joining
us yeah for sure oh thank y'all all
right take it easy brother
yeah
he's the man he is the man yeah he's
dope man
uh and then he reminded me it was
perfect it's like he's uh professionally
segwaying okay
check out that merch I need a shirt man
I told you you told me I'll be back um
uh the meetings not ended but he's gone
okay just making sure yeah uh we were
only gonna say good things about him
it's okay I'm always worried someone's
gonna make a joke or something yeah I
had an idea
that's funny no one was rooting at all
people wanted
I'm a Tony Kelly guy can you believe
this [ __ ] guy all right take your
heart out but he reminded me something
you got roofied we never finished well I
don't want to hear about that too wait
what I didn't I didn't get roofied in
just more so one of those God damn Nick
what kind of Segway is this but uh yeah
no no no just based in a room it's just
that I can't hold my alcohol
sometimes when they had these uh alcohol
percentages on those cans I think
they're lying to you right they say it's
like 12 13 that [ __ ] is on a can this
cup that's huge dog that's like crazy
that's a crazy one that's a pretty
potent drink I had
cut water ever heard of cut water it's
like these uh I went to the Dodgers game
and uh it was basically they had these
like cans and it's like I love sweeter
drinks okay so it's like a lime
Margarita type Vibe and uh bro that
should have [ __ ] you up for real
Uncle Margarita things yeah definitely
the margarita thing [ __ ] you up yeah
it was a lot of margaritas man yeah they
have you ever had the strawberitas
I'm gonna like out myself the first time
the first time I uh drank after I turned
21 uh I went to Korean barbecue with my
brother and uh I I TR I chugged a uh
half of a strawberita in the parking lot
on empty stomach before and then we
started doing shots of Soju in the
restaurant and at the time I I hadn't
drank it I hadn't eaten yet so I was
still going on a empty stomach and it
all started to hit me to the point where
I had to get up or where I was gonna
throw up and um on my way out I didn't
make it and I tried to cover my oh no oh
my mouth and throw up into my hand but
however
um I don't think the innocent uh family
enjoying their Korean barbecue uh was
too thrilled to have throw up rain down
on them
yeah yeah it was a tough I don't care
yeah just thought it was I threw up on a
family of four I had a Korean barbecue
was not allowed back there's a photo
yeah
I threw up at the bar on my 21st
birthday Brothers
but uh yeah what'd you say brothers in
the cross oh brother's in Lacrosse it's
a bar oh okay again uh shouldn't I have
to box I almost closed the show we have
this box I'll go get I can't I wish I
could watch our boss but I gotta go yeah
yeah I got I gotta hit a heart out but
you know I appreciate y'all man y'all
I'm calling your boy yo man Bros we
gotta we got a hoop man yeah yeah
I would I would have you out there with
me bro but you wearing 155. just someone
says
I'm like oh [ __ ]
or it makes you very aerodynamic and
you're just like able to jump yeah
duck get like a paper mache he flies
away
Space Jam style bro I don't know Nick
not at no 155 you can't hoop with us for
real
no we we we play pretty hard yeah I'm
about to go all right all right bro well
you already did everything right oh you
plug your stuff
if you're on Instagram how's your women
uh portfolio y'all got a lot of women
following y'all oh God no problem
well I don't even want to put on my
Instagram name because I don't need no
you should still do it but I'm joking
all right no just no you're getting the
dude followers see the numbers what's
this guy do he must do something yeah
it's true Justin I will be honest with
you when I first started with them um I
would think you would think there's a
lot of female followers but it's just a
lot of dues with female names yeah yeah
like I had like at least 10 guys named
Madison follow me on Instagram and it
was very um
you know you know Bros it's all good to
have Bros around because you are the
plug when it comes to drip let me know
let me know let me know but uh yeah
Justin Elliott when everything Facebook
Instagram
um your podcast what was the name of
that again think before you speak I'm
also only fans as well you did get the
uh your name back on Instagram I did get
my my Instagram name back uh got my I
got my only fans popping it's just a
whole lot of thick women on there so we
gotta like it say what's up what's
happening wait what
now I'm thinking about doing only fans
that just just can't waste this plug you
just got this legit plug I thought it
was a real house
no no all right all right well thanks
thanks for joining sorry I appreciate
y'all don't get yourself an uncut
We Appreciate You Justin let's make it
back who do you got this fight yeah I
can't see so
Nick what do you want to do head body or
just body see I don't like that you are
making me be the one decide because that
makes me seem aggressive and like
just setting up to it was like what uh
Justin asked about you like cocky at the
weigh-in like I'm like oh headshot and
then you do better than me but we both
wanted headshots we both want to do
headshots just say you want to do
headshots too I just feel like when I
when I read the temperature in the room
it didn't seem like you really want to
do headshots oh now he's now he's like
I'm just saying it sounds like you want
to do it and then you're fine you're so
hey girl let's do headshots she picked
the harder gloves too headshots it is
all right you have a bigger Target for
your head though I'm not gonna I know
dude that's exactly so I'm putting
myself in a disadvantage would you like
would you want to switch one glove for
one glove I did not intentionally pick
the harder gloves
use the pears come on now he plants the
seed of doubt and then I try to give him
a solution he goes oh good I'll go to
good
oh the psychological out we can
investigate the gloves later we know the
blue ones in the left in the Red Corner
we got sitting at six two
199 pounds
someone has to do the timer yeah I got a
timer I'll tell you when there's 10
seconds or are you gonna introduce us I
was doing it before you guys rudely
interrupted
we got in the Red Corner standing at six
two
199 pounds
going against in the blue Corner
standing at 6-1
187 pounds Nick Davis
whoa I call him Davies
all right boys I want a clean fight
touch gloves if you want and start tell
us when
yeah ready go
see a lot of a lot of glove moving
touching gloves touching gloves
oh oh low light tap
Nick Davis with the pillows this is
going low Nick Davis with the pillow
hands keeping his hands down oh no oh
face shot
foreign
to connect with Nick's chin which is
ironic there we go
great job by chin great job oh nice shot
Nick with another body shot another body
shot chin with a shot up top
[Music]
[ __ ] he's throwing the dick punches it
looks like
I promise that he's back he still cares
about the set real producer
keep going boys this has to be the
saddest fight I have ever seen ten nine
eight seven six five four three two one
I wanna hurt each other
that is not true because Nick kept
throwing dick punches from his
dick once I'm saying like the way where
you were throwing them from you were
throwing it from your own dick we're
gonna have to go to the body shots only
this one might have to go to a decision
this might have to go to decision I mean
mate yeah
we gotta
wait judges judges are looking at the
scorecards give us a minute while the
judges score the fight is there really
winner
I guess we have to
um
well you know it looks like it looks
like there is a split decision
it looks like there's a split decision
so either we need to set up a rematch or
we can go to the video replay and see if
the video guy Kyle video guys I couldn't
think of the term don't tell you how to
get the money
look I'm listening even out of Bradley's
still coaching we can either set up a
rematch between chin and Nick or
can be the determined factor I have chin
winning browse has Nick
Kyle
commission but whatever
isn't it crazy how out of breath though
after one minute I I knew I knew it was
like that but it is crazy it is when
it's especially body shots too because
it's more taxing on you like can we
drink
you make me feel bad because okay you
won't throw as much as me and it's like
I'm trying to get you guys Nick was
being a little more yeah I think per
capita Nick Nick definitely threw I will
say Nick Nick I was trying to get like
Nick didn't throw hard but looking at it
he did con he did have more Taps to the
body chin did have more Taps of the head
but points looking looking I'm sorry
looking back at it I'm going to have to
recant my previous statement as much as
I regret this but I would like to say
that I believe
two to one Nick two to one Nick I love
that I love that chin gave me a free
t-shirt last week and I love it get the
code uh in this episode uh buy it but
Nick through more and that Dodge for
style points won the fight for me it's
gonna be a good highlight I felt it it
was right it was right on my nose yeah
thank you so the guys on the team
say Nick one even though we all know
I connected a bunch you through
less the number one shot was when you
popped me in the nose which I was fine
with I would love I I was bored to get
my ass kicked in a ring I think I just I
like oh man
that's fun that was good that was good
you're sweating you guys were a pretty
good match
Nick is sweating so much it looks like
he's detoxing right now
that was a great matchup though you guys
had a good fight I think it was really
lackluster I think we do need to set up
me and George went way harder I still
have bruised ribs from two weeks ago
yeah that was it's a tough it's a tough
follow-up it's a tough fight after that
I will say that but now that I hear all
this talk about how Nick do so much and
I didn't do much yeah we will have a
rematch oh okay
I have to spin the wheel yeah we have to
spin the wheel oh man how about you guys
save that rematch for when you cut the
weight and you're doing a different
weight class when he's super loud I just
the fight the wheel decides that's true
that's all right ready we're gonna get
do that
Nick back your back fights we'll decide
if you look at that concentration too
first Nick
perhaps oh that's a great Magic
all right I'm down
you want to do headgear and headshots
I'd be I got I got headgear I got
headgear at my place I got two different
headgears I got the one with the bar in
front and I got the stuff uh the uh the
other one I'm down okay and you're gonna
be like 150 pounds by the time we fight
oh yeah I'm like 185 right now Bros I
will let you know the headgear does not
help with concussions at all it just
keeps you from getting cut it feels a
little nicer though just to be able to
yeah and uh yeah I don't know I am going
to be pretty uh me
absolutely [ __ ] I forgot the other thing
I was just
so this is next week okay next week for
house
I can't remember I'm not gonna lie dude
I've really just recovered from the rib
shots like yesterday it's been crazy I
couldn't do sit-ups I couldn't do
anything
and Christian I'm very coachable I am
listening I throw in from my deck but it
felt like that's what I'm guarding
against because he's not throwing to the
head but you're right I have to bring it
back to the team or even even if you're
throwing from the body if you keep your
things right here and just throw silly
Philly Philly yeah yeah you do a lot of
uppercuts no I love I'm listening I'm
listening I [ __ ] love it it's so it's
so fun
the Highlight Reel is going to be dope
definitely slow
you know we sponsored a fighter like
saying
say chin takes uh brows under his wing
for a week and I take you onto my wing
for a week and then we coat like one day
we go to the gym train you for the fight
look we have like a one day training
camp before each fight maybe with all
due respect
we spend enough time together it's just
two days a week lots of coaches that's
your cutoff yeah I'm not I'm just being
an adult male that's basically my cat
yeah yeah two days a week I was just
saying in general I it's going to be
Nick you know also
no I've we can cut this out I was
thinking about it when we had them on
Zoom
could be a dumb idea what if we had like
a tournament and maybe if he ever like
if we have agent like if Adrian's ever
in LA or we fly him out Winner Takes
Adrian or something like that
yeah we got we gotta wrap this show up
let's get plugged in we're promising way
too many fly outs all right
uh uh let's get let's get the plugs in
God damn whatever I said it was gonna be
Chewie knows when then to show I get it
sit
leave it
that's great all right
ah
it's okay
it adds to the after dark effect
I would love to get out for traffic
[Laughter]
beautiful
all right great episode guys great
episode guys Shane where can we find you
plugs hold on I was gonna say uh the
fight club's evolving it might have
devolved here but the point is we're
keeping it going right
uh I I it was pretty fun fight
it's gonna get harder and harder
it makes me want to train
amazing
I [ __ ] rang his Bell evidently
Mike's upside down it's gonna get harder
and harder for 10 years he's like
[Music]
look how confident Nick seems I'm
confident okay he would yeah
um so all I care about right now my main
thing
is everyone here is healthy especially
Nick because we had a pretty hardcore
fight
I think I might have hurt my head when I
was a child and that gave me my risk
taking this position to be honest you
only might be like correcting stuff but
so Nick's wearing a beautiful shirt so
is
Christian AKA meatball
uh you can get that shirt that I helped
design with into the end it was a really
fun project it took a lot of time I love
it so much and this is like a a very
proud moment for me so I love you guys
to buy one uh in today m.com chin Dash T
but Nick will leave a link below and me
and brows are in concert August 26th in
Portsmouth Ohio yeah we'll post about
that on our IGS yep I think that's
pretty much it for me what do you guys
got
a shout out to the director of
cinematography for cats after dark Fight
Club Kyle Varney you did a great job
thank you guys thanks for having me
we'll replay my Raphael physio uh
go back into Dodge right here
that was awesome thanks shout out Kyle
uh where can they find you Kyle thank
you
let me get on a bike before Nick yells
um
you can find me at Kyle Varney
underscore on Instagram and you know
send me your mom's phone number thank
you that's that's nice
you're Ohio boys if she has any fights
yeah filmed is what he meant or anything
else that she needs filmed
all right
another podcast show check it out
um
I can't remember any stuff we did oh
yeah vote Yes on Prop 27. what's up Bros
brows at lowbrows Instagram me and Chen
have a show coming up August 26th
honestly if you listen to this and
you're in Ohio Kentucky West Virginia
anywhere in the Midwest and you want to
come we would love to see you there we
might do a little contest to bring
someone out we're still going to talk
about that but it's gonna be a cool show
that's what we have planned yeah Nick's
still breathing heavy just letting you
guys know oh yeah I'm extremely out of
shape
uh that was that was a fun one guys all
right good one later oh did you not did
you not do it no I didn't but it's all
good okay
just uh see Palo 6 on Instagram and
please check out
um the you already know podcast on
YouTube Spotify uh Apple podcast and uh
this week we are dropping the merch for
their podcast and I help design the
website so please go and check it out uh
you already knowpodcast.com and um yeah
I feel like you should have to tell
people about that show believe me I know
it's kind of wild it's kind of wild I
mean because of the name it was just a
pun but it's all good it's all good you
already know oh yeah
oh my God you should start saying that
after like I shouldn't have to tell you
you already know
you're welcome Christian all right
goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]